hello guys i'm ryan right i'm jerry
jerry night today we're gonna do a
little special video where we're gonna
recommend five movies that we think
you'd enjoy this Halloween my number
five choice would have to be poltergeist
poltergeist the original not the sam
rockwell one the original it was a movie
that started a lot of trends i love the
tone of it because the film has this
incredible ability to go between horror
terror and also a sense of wonder and
awe about ghosts because there is both
of that you know like they're in life
you do have a sense of wonder like i
like when that goes first appear and
they're like hell look at this chair
trick that we can do and look out we
could slide across the floor and then
terrifying [ __ ] starts going down and i
like that it was a better approach than
what we get out innocent and then what
people have been a ping it ever since
you know it's like it starts out
innocent enough and then it becomes
sinister absolutely and is a fantastic
[ __ ] film one of the best classics of
horror films i've ever seen oh yeah
that's a nice blend because you get that
Spielberg you sense of wonder with that
tobe Hooper sense of terror after a
while yeah I movie is scarier than the
PG would have you believe oh yeah is
more violent than a deadly blue he's
turning off his face and [ __ ] yeah I was
like I can't believe this is PG yeah
yeah so my number five for this list I
like to slip in you know with some some
quirky horror so I'm going evil dead too
good cuz you know ash Deadites demons
and stuff it's quirky but it's also like
creepy and scary and only the way that
like zany things can be yeah they're
like they're still threatening but
they're kind of weird and it's just so
much fun that's a nice way to slip in
cuz you get a little bit of scaring a
little bit of fun that's the kind of
style that only Sam Raimi can pull off
yeah I mean he's the master yeah you
like really defined his style with that
movie I think yeah yeah well cause like
you know the first one is kind of rough
around the edges in it it has both of
those elements but the second one is
like ah here is like the masterful like
you have conquered this idea my number
four would have to be one of the best
horror comedies I've ever seen shaun of
the dead if you're in the mood for a fun
horror vie because to me Halloween is
about not just the fear but also about
fun I feel like Shaun of the Dead
really provides both elements so well it
introduces a simon pegg Edgar Wright
Nick Frost it's just a fantastically
entertaining time where the characters
are so fun to watch and there's good
zombie thrills I think if the film is
[ __ ] perfect so my number 4 um I went
with Halloween and I'm gonna leave it up
to whichever Halloween you want to watch
whether it be John Carpenter's or Rob
Zombie's cuz I want a few people who
really liked both iterations for
entirely different reasons I don't know
which one I would throw on maybe I'll
put them on at the same time John
Carter's Halloween is a classic and it's
it takes place on the day and I think
Rob Zombie's has some very sinister and
very cool stuff about it too and you
know i will say Rob Zombie's Halloween I
know I didn't get the best critical
feedback and its really split amongst
audiences I personally enjoyed that
phone yeah I did too i I really think
there's a lot of effective stuff and
every time I rewatching I'm like you
know what man [ __ ] the haters yeah my
number three choice would have to be
drag me to hell yeah I love it because
it's one of those films that's about the
consequence of choice you know what
choice do you make they really put this
character in a position where you're
like what choice you're gonna make and
it's gonna have a certain outcome for
you if you don't make the right choice
there villain in it the old lady [ __ ]
terrifying that's where I thought that
they cast like a foreign lady for this
role I had no idea they cast an american
chick you know oh she american i mean
you know it's not entirely like a huge
stretch to play like a Slovak like a
gypsy like she's got the body language
down she's got you this she has every
mannerism down she's entirely convincing
and it's cool to have a horror more like
little old lady is terrifying and like
really powerful you know and it's quirky
at times it's fun at times it's another
Sam Raimi film that only Sam Raimi can
pull off yeah it was the perfect return
to form I love the ending love the way
that film [ __ ] I did I would we
should probably do a review of all these
[ __ ] movies at somebody eventually
keep this on a list my number three it
was actually your number 4 i'm going
with shaun of the dead as well i'm doing
like a trick and treat sort of back and
forth so Sean the dead kind of like evil
dead two is fun and also kind of scary
it's a very honest zombie movie while
it's you know witty and upbeat and stuff
like that you know it has a lot of the
moods
things like Dawn of the Dead have very
authentic with that scene where they
pull him through the window and just rip
his whole body apart in their guts of
her like that's straight out of one of
those movies so it has all the charms of
a great zombie classic with some great
british humor yeah it's it's perfect
what one other thing I wanted to point
about that movie is has some credible
ability to scare you and then a second
later make you laugh yeah you know
because of the reaction of the
characters yeah it doesn't feel like a
comedy it still feels like a zombie
movie it just happens to be funny my
number two is actually probably my
favorite horror film of all time which
is scream everyone knows it's very meta
it's a great play on horror you know it
has the the classic drew Barrymore
opening prologue it was such an
entertaining [ __ ] film it's one of
those movies that's scary because yeah
this could really happen because it's a
serial killer and it toys with the idea
of what if a killer is inspired by
horror movies well it's a big cultural
fear has been for a long time absolutely
and there's also good humor infused in
neb Campbell's great in it it's a horror
film about horror fans yeah and i will
say like scream too i also think is very
good as well oh [ __ ] yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
man in that movie he's good and so is
Jerry O'Connell jerry okolo ok so my
number 2 i'm going back to trick is the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre the original 73
Texas Chainsaw Massacre I mean this is
to me I think it's a perfect film it's
just so jarring and strange and just
stuff kinda just happens and unfold it's
really disconcerting and it's just great
you know it has all those things that
people love about 70s horror and damn
does it feel real yeah it really does
feels [ __ ] real movie like a fly on
the wall is very upsetting situation
it's not like the remake word you know
it's like fast-paced yeah i mean the
remake of shy I like to remake to the
remake is shinier and yeah that's more
like Hollywood thrills as opposed to the
original which is like just [ __ ]
terrifying just grimy and you feel hot
watching it yeah it's it's fantastic
it's not about Halloween but i would
have to pull that one out absolutely
halloween our number one happens to be
the same
Rick a tree for tree that film is the
best Halloween film I'd recommend it's
not my favorite horror movie but it's my
favorite Halloween movie hands down it
manages to like tell so many different
stories in this anthology and all of
them feel like these urban legend myths
kind of vibe to it there's a scary
stories you would tell with your friends
or something like that you know they're
the small town urban myths and all that
and I mean it's so many horror movies
you know people the misconceptions like
oh you know October that's the time for
horror movies most horror movies aren't
ya about or even having you know don't
feel like Halloween and trick-or-treat
is about Halloween it's about the
traditions it's about why we carve
jack-o'-lanterns and why would give out
candy even the spirit of Halloween isn't
is personified in the movie it's all
about this spirit of Halloween and
that's where the horrors coming from is
the spirit and the legend you know like
you don't put out the jack-o'-lantern
you don't you got to keep it lit you
know that's the start of it just sets up
the whole vibe of it oh yeah and it's
got great character time it's got great
tie-ins through all the [ __ ] stories
yeah things collide in these interesting
little ways you know it's not your
creeps gerontology where everything's
separate it's this small town you know
yeah celebrating Halloween and all their
various different ways that is funny too
ya got a gamer like when we watch it
it's gonna slide it's got a very
mischievous sense of humor when we watch
in the theaters we went to a
pre-screening because for some reason
this movie didn't get at the actual
release which is like the stupidest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard yeah
there's like it's one of those movies I
went straight to DVD but you look up the
reviews for it you're like this film has
incredible reviews everybody really like
everybody loves it and it's like a cult
classic because it is just a [ __ ]
great film you know and it manages to be
funny into some of the sickest ways you
know I mean we definitely twisted who
plays the serial killer dylan baker
bella beyle bake like there's a scene
where he's trying to get rid of a body
and it's so [ __ ] violent and just
like what's unnecessary alike or
anything but it is like it's sick it's
in it's very darkly funny yeah but it's
really funny at the same time it's the
best Halloween movie yeah it's a great
it's a great Halloween and of course if
you have a list like this you got to
have honorable mentions to keep this
video efficient we're probably going to
list off our honorable mentions fine
like
said evil that too I like the original
Evil Dead a lot actually that I don't
even think about the remake to the
remakes all three sarina if you're if
you're into course I'm Evil Dead merit
yeah just watch all the [ __ ] evil
dad's an army of darkness you'll have a
great [ __ ] time yeah you'll feel like
I love grindhouse I think that's a great
film to watch on Halloween time I really
like American cycle as well it's a cult
classic about a serial killer that's
another film that I love horror films
that manage to also be funny at the same
time you know an American Psycho because
people have humor you know yeah american
psycho is a character study of this
psychopath yet he's really likable oh
you know like dude [ __ ] insane but he
makes you laugh that's what's cool about
that movie those he can be likable but I
never liked it cuz you always know what
a bad guy he is and how insincere his
liability entertaining a watch Oh
totally yeah but you know even when he's
likable you know how insincere is I want
to fit it there's a lot of quads hurting
video today yess i was probably
returning some videotape do you need a
line like you get you i can get you
alive nice Roger would be a great one to
throw a Halloween like the original
silent movie is awesome night living
dead i love that movie that's kind of a
halloween time i'd say dawn of the dead
to donna the dead yet to both both
versions i think are really good I'm
house on Haunted Hill I always enjoy the
original on Halloween if you looking for
slasher Jason lives is always my
favorite name see is always doing
marathons of Jason movies yeah there's
classics like The Nightmare on Elm
Street the Halloween yeah Jason sleepy
hollow sleepy Hall of it you know what
that's a great choice actually to get
yeah I like that that's a great choices
or is that like spooky vibe throughout
it has a legendary tale vibe to it to ya
house of a dozen course that one second
house of a dozen corpses is it great
yeah it's like we're choosing movies
that are primarily fun some of them are
not like fun but most of them are like
fun horror films yeah that one's all
zamian and it's very you know mccubbin
very over-the-top it's very Halloween in
that sense a film I loved growing up was
um creepshow I'll growing up I might
throw in a Saw movie just cuz I like saw
one I'm really calling on early I'm
Halloween by the end even though for
years it was if it's hella weed it must
be sorry
like it doesn't have to be like I'm
valuing a lot of crap and this does if
you're on the internet you shouldn't
like this but I like the first
paranormal activity people like 930
Hawaii and I have liked marked ones a
lot I feel like part 3 would be the best
Halloween vibe out of all the paranormal
activities because it's just for fun and
scary at the same time Alton I wish they
would have done is just because they
could easily just incidentally put one
at Halloween yeah and I really wish they
had cuz that would have been cool is
like experiencing a ghost you know
haunting thing during Halloween where
you all have like these these creepy
props around anyway in these decorations
like yeah I think that would be really
fun ver six my time I throw on Lords of
Salem yeah motifs and that has ADD ready
and it has a surreal pneus that I would
throw on like an on a Halloween
afternoon it would be it would be it
would be in the mix if you couldn't tell
him around the devil's advocate Keanu
Reeves on Gina look at me guys that's
our list for today they gave like [ __ ]
10 more honorable mention so we did Earl
because it's like you pictures just so
many good there's so many of horror
movies to throw on man I'm still coming
up with them yeah I just want to say the
thing out loud or do yeah absolutely no
John Carpenter has a whole [ __ ] limb
West Craven two winters wishmaster and
stuff dude there's there's my soul to
take there's Hellraiser hey Clive Barker
is has an aesthetic unto himself anyway
guys that's it for today if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe today
and become a reject ahorrar move what
does that involve that involves
prostitutes and you reject them and you
can check out reasons to jerry and dank
ass tubs on this channel hosted by said
jerry and you can follow us on our
social networks and you guys have a
happy Halloween happy house so make sure
to pull a trick or a treat I prefer
tricks you know what's funny is if you
like jerk off on your rooftop and then
come on on the adults who are walking to
the doorstep that's not that you could
get you could become a registered sex
offender from doing on our own I want to
see the rule that establishes that
personal mean I've come on many adults